so you refer to people including
yourself who gravitate toward a kind of
computational thinking as geeks for at
least I've heard you use that
terminology it true that I think there's
something that happened to me as I was
growing up that made my brain structure
in a certain way that that resonates
with with computers so there's this
space of people it's 2% of the
population you empirically estimate
that's a prick that's been proven a
fairly constant over most of my career
however it might be different now
because kids have different experiences
when they're young so obviously what
does the world look like to a geek what
is what is this aspect of thinking that
is unique to their makes it yeah that
makes a geek this is cuter the important
question in in the 50s IBM noticed that
that there were geeks or non geeks and
so they tried to hire geeks and they put
out ads with paper saying you know if
you play chess come to Madison Avenue
and for an interview or something like
this you know they were they were trying
for some things so what it what what is
it that I find easy and other people
tend to find harder and and I think
there's two main things one is this with
is ability to jump jump levels of
abstraction so you see something in the
larger and you see something in the
small and and and you pass between those
unconsciously so you know that in order
to solve some big problem what you need
to do is add one to a into a certain
register or anything that gets it to
another step and you can't and below the
yeah I mean I don't go down to the
electron level but I knew what those
milliseconds were what the drum was like
on the 650 I knew how I was gonna factor
her number or or find a root of an
equation or something be out of it
because
what was doing and and as I'm debugging
I'm going through you know did I make a
keep on chair did I did I write the
wrong instruction do I have the wrong
wrong thing in a register and each level
like each level it is different and that
this idea of being able to see something
at all at lots of levels and fluently go
between them it seems to me to be more
pronounced much more pronounced in in
the people that resonate with computers
like my god so in my books I also don't
stick just to the high level but but i
but I mix low level stuff with high
level and this means that some people
think you know that Wow
that I should write better books and
it's probably true but but other people
say well but that's if you think like
like that then that's the way to train
yourself to keep mixing the levels and
and learn more and more how to jump
between so that that's the one thing the
other the other thing is that it's more
of a talent it's to be able to deal with
non-uniformity boy where there's case
one case two case three instead of
instead of having one or two rules that
govern everything so if so it doesn't
bother me if I need like an algorithm
has ten steps to it you know each step
is does something else that doesn't
bother me but a lot of a lot of pure
mathematics is based on one or two rules
which which are universal and and and so
this means that people like me sometimes
work with systems that are more
complicated than necessary because it
doesn't bother us that we don't that we
didn't figure out the simple rule and
you mentioned that while Jacobi boule
Abel and all the mathematicians in 19th
century may have had symptoms of geek
the first 100 percent legit geek was
touring Alan Torrie I think he had
a lot more of this quality than anybody
did from reading the kind of stuff he
did and so how does touring what
influence has touring had on you well
well your waiting so I didn't know that
aspect of him until after I graduated
some years I it has undergraduate we had
a class that talked about computability
theory and Turing machines and and that
was all it sounded like a very specific
kind of purely theoretical approach to
stuff
so when how old was I when I when I
learned that he that he had you know God
designed machine and that he wrote the
know you wrote a wonderful manual for
for Manchester machines and and he
invented all subroutines and and and he
was a real hacker that that he has hands
dirty
that I thought for many years that he
had only done purely formal work as I
started reading his own publications I
could yeah you know I could feel this
kinship and and because he had a lot of
peculiarities thinking he wrote numbers
backwards because I mean left to rights
to the right to left because that's the
that's it was easier for computers to
process him that way what do you mean
left to right he would write PI as you
know nine five one four point three I
mean okay right I get it
for one point three on the blackboard I
mean when he he we had drain himself to
I to do that because the computers he
was working with I worked that way
inside trained himself to think like a
computer well there you go
that's not gig thinking yeah
you